That previous video, was really long.
Before we continue, I want to share with you this one question a lot of
students ask me, when I teach them programming, and that question is,
how did I learn all of this stuff?
Well, the true answer is, I searched for and read documentation.
I Googled for how to create an action, in Xcode.
And here, I landed on a help page created by Apple.
This page demonstrated how to make a connection between a button, and code.
So it is in this spirit of figuring out new things while reading documentation,
I want to present a couple of challenges to you,
that you can help find the answers for.
Your first question.
What does this tiny circle do?
You can find the circle.
Right next to the action, in the gutter.
And your second question, is what does this tiny icon do?
This icon is called Connections Inspector.
And you can find it in the Utility area.
You can enter your responses, in these boxes.